kevin let me ask you this
i love your stand-up it's so good it's
observational it's based on real life
and if you love chris farley you get
some of that but kevin's his own man in
a brilliant comic my question is you
know he had those spade i love spade
right and sandler and those guys were so
close to chris and when when you're
around you there are similarities in
personality do they try to hang out with
you do they talk to you keep the
relationship going and kind of feel like
they still have chris in their life a
little bit well sometimes i don't see
him as much as i did obviously life gets
in the way but i used to hang out when i
was in l.a i used to hang out with those
guys a lot more than i did now but i
don't hang out with them as much because
you know just people get families and
that kind of thing and but yeah i think
probably that was some of that sure i
think there was probably some of that
but i think
they miss him so much in uh people loved
him you know and and that's the legacy
that he has is uh his friends really
loved him and everyone on snl always
spoke highly yeah man it was so powerful
when you hear those guys i mean their
lives were really really ruined for a
little bit i mean spade couldn't go to
the funeral am i correct yeah no that
was too much he called and said i can't
really do it and
you know i understand i mean it's it's
it's uh it was a that was a dark dark
those were dark days you know and uh my
dad passed away a couple years after
that so
yeah we went through our tough time
definitely during those you know during
those time but that was for everybody
and the funeral itself was really really
that was one of the most moving things
just to see people how much she touched
people's lives you know so i'm i'm proud
of him for that you know
for all of his faults that he had he had
a huge heart and he touched people uh
and and got to people and and so he
lives that's his legacy and so you know
i look back and you know i i'm proud of
him for that you know so that's that's
that's a great thing for sure yeah no
one ever forget chris farley that's for
damn sure i mean he just had that that
power i mean you could not watch him and
not be moved affected and really have
this lingering affection for him because
he was so lovable and so real and he was
so daring and willing to go out there
yeah he lived like he he lived like
right out there you know where uh and
you kind of worried about him at the
same time like as his brother i'm like
oh
it's like a tightrope if you enjoyed
this short clip click over here to watch
another short clip and if you want to
watch the entire episode the entire
podcast click here
[Music]